okay could you do just like 50 50  custody with him would he want to do  that  because of his career he most likely  would not he'd be awarded because he  play he's on the road so much  um I'm very open-minded whenever he  wants to see our son and come get him  like he's getting them from the the 29th  to the 7th like because he's traveling  on this two-week period right now so  anytime he wants him I let him see him  like I mean he's I I love PJ that's why  I had a baby with him so despite like  all our [ __ ] that's been out there and  how hard it has been transitioning from  romantic to like basically strangers  that we got a co-parent now  um I still love him I love him to death  you know but um yeah so with the custody  stuff I'm very open-minded I just think  with his career it would be hard for a  judge to like award him 50 50. just  because he travels so much